let's start with those kovid jabs are
they going to be scrapped well this is a
policy that we've always kept under
review and we've been trying to strike
throughout this pandemic the right
balance between having the the maximum
impact in terms of measures that support
public safety in the face of the virus
but also have the minimum impact in
terms of our wider freedoms as a society
and it's in that context that the
decision was made last autumn to make
sure that we uh went went ahead with the
manchester vaccination policy and that
was because obviously we had the delta
variant extremely dangerous taking a
huge toll on our society and we wanted
to make sure that people going into
hospital very vulnerable people whether
they had covered or another condition
which required treatment weren't going
to be faced with an increased risk of
infection on the wards
we continue uh to monitor that situation
very very closely what we know about
omicron is that it is much more
transmissible but less severe any
decision that's taken uh this week will
reflect that reality i i can't prejudge
uh the decision that that is going to be
made but obviously we do recognize those
realities and that does open a space i
just want to play well we can look at
this again for some answer i want to
play you this uh this grab and see
whether this is uh why there was the
change of heart here we go
maybe there's an opportunity to
reconsider with omicron and the changing
picture or at least the nuance it will
allow doctors who've had antibody
exposure
who've got antibodies who haven't had
the vaccination
to not have it
there you go so he was challenged the
health secretary was embarrassed around
80 000 health healthcare workers are
still unvaccinated what's going to
happen to them now
well it has to be seen in in in the
wider context there are 1.2 million uh
full-time equivalent staff in the nhs
that's actually gone up 45 000 over the
last year so it's a well staffed service
but obviously it's not much well-stocked
well it's very short stuff well actually
it's it's not it's got 45 000 more
full-time equivalent stuff in it than it
had a thousand care staff lost their
jobs because they hadn't been vaccinated
well
look that's separate from the nhs we've
got 45 000 more staff than we had a year
ago 1.2 million in in total full-time
equivalent and we always want to make
sure those members stay guys and lost
their job we always want to make sure
that those numbers stay as robust as
they uh can possibly be and that we can
provide the best possible care but we
also as i say have to balance that
against the
the reality that if you are not
vaccinated then you do obviously pose
more of a threat both to yourself your
colleagues and to patients and that is
and that is the stark reality of a
highly transmissible very dangerous
virus that's why we have taken measures
we have obviously when it comes to
omicron and the fact that the virus has
mutated we continue to monitor the
impact of of wider policy so what about
those people there's 80 000 healthcare
workers who are still waiting to find
out whether they're going to keep their
jobs or not from april what's going to
happen well uh there will be a decision
made in in the in the course of the next
few days and that's that opens the
window as i say for us to look at this
uh nhs waiting lists for for key
treatments going up as a result of the
backlogging care flowing from the
pandemic the nhs uh and social care levy
that is going to allow us to do 9
million more scans checks and operations
things which will bear down on that
backlog make sure we can get back uh to
normal and also address what we all know
to be the long-term challenge of an
aging society in terms of a sustainable
solution
social care steady on
the tory manifesto 2019 we promise not
to raise the rates of income tax
national insurance or vat
this is a tax guarantee that will
protect the incomes of hard-working
families across the next parliament yeah
and look i'm a low-tax conservative i
think everyone who's done on that
manifesto was proud of the fact that we
committed not to
uh to raise taxes but no one could have
could have reckoned with the impact of
what we've seen over the last two years
it's been an extraordinary event we've
spent over 400 billion pounds responding
to coronavirus and obviously that's
allowed us to both keep the health
service running but also to introduce
things like the furlough scheme which
has saved literally millions of jobs
it's in that context that we've incurred
these huge debts it's in that context as
well that we've
accumulated these nhs backlogs and we
have to be honest with people we can
either pay for more treatments by
whacking up borrowing which is just
taxes deferred for the next generation
or we can deal with it responsibly now
here's a thought why don't we do this
instead why don't we use that 350
million quid a week that we were
promised that would amount to
18.2 billion pounds a year for our
national health service which we heard
so much about during brexit which is 6.2
billion pounds more than what the
national insurance
rise will uh will get i'm not sure if we
got a picture of the bus just to make
the point well i mean as someone who
supported brexit i'm delighted that
we're no longer sending that money to
brussels but we were told that it was
going to be useful and and indeed if you
remember theresa may in 2018
specifically did repurpose the side of
the boss yeah and and that money is now
in the nhs this is the point where
theresa may unleashed
a record funding session calculated
well no because we've retreat we've got
more of a backhoe in the nhs than anyone
knew but for the 70th anniversary of the
the nhs back in 2018 to the nhs we gave
a record expert we gave a record that
you promised on the side of that bus we
gave a funding settlement to the nhs
which was actually larger than that some
and that was theresa may's announcement
back in 2018. okay so the people that
are facing a 10 increase in their
national insurance contribution someone
earning 30 000 pounds will now pay 270
pounds more a year given that the cost
of living is increasing given that the
um the uh
heating the homes is just going to be
almost impossible for so many people
going up perhaps a thousand pounds where
are they going to find the money from
well the cost of living is is is a major
issue it's important though to be clear
about what the health and social care
levy will cost the six million lowest
earners won't pay anything extra uh and
fifty at the top 15 percent of earners
will pay
almost half the cost of the policy so
it's a very progressive policy for for
your average uh for your average uh
taxpayer this is a question of literally
uh three or four pounds more per week in
the context of bearing down on this
huge back cog as i say have accumulated
uh waiting lists we have to make sure
that we can fund that sustainably as i
said the only alternative every single
penny will go to the national house
it will yes this is an entirely
dedicated tax for those purposes it goes
it goes nowhere else you when you've
lied to us before well uh with respect
kay i i i haven't and no and when i say
you i meant you're representing the
government this morning so collectively
i've just showed you how you did we we
didn't lie we we we made it economical
with the actuality no we we we made a
commitment in in 2019 that we weren't
going to raise taxes that was before a
global pandemic which has cost hundreds
of thousands of lives it's it's
accumulated a
enormous backlogging care and we have to
make uh responsible decisions i think
you know a conservative government will
always take a fiscally responsible route
and it is simply irresponsible for us to
say we're going to whack all of this on
on on our debt when we know that is
already extremely large at a record high
and crucially when a one percent rise in
interest rates will cost us an extra 23
billion yeah always honest with us he is
are you sure yeah i i absolutely do i'm
very proud to be a member of his
government okay so uh the fact that he
has basically said that he wasn't aware
of parties at number 10 it's been proven
that not only was he aware of them but
he was also at them it's also been
proven that he uh
mislead parliament um let's not over
complicate the matter
uh given what sue gray has what we're
hearing sue gray has been investigating
the police are investigating he should
just resign no well look uh the sugray
report will come forward soon and
obviously i i don't know exactly when
that's a matter of fault for sugray uh
to decide
uh and when she does the premise has
been clear he'll come to parliament to
make a further uh statement based on all
the facts but look the prime minister is
a good man he's a good leader and i
think no i think i think it's very
important that we allow an independent
act twice relying i think we once from
the uh a national newspaper and once by
michael howard i think it is absolutely
vital and we don't that we don't
prejudge what sue grey is going to say
or indeed what the met police are
investigating you said he doesn't lie
and i've made a point i've just
illustrated twice i have total
confidence in the prime minister but you
said he didn't lie i i do not believe
that he does lie okay so why do you
think he was sacked by the times for
lying i i okay i i i don't think this is
michael howard for life i don't know the
circumstances absolutely
i don't know the circumstances on three
occasions
previous employment okay that's that's
simply uh michael howard works for the
conservative party look the the
decisions about who was on the shadow
front bench uh
15 years ago uh and and the precise
circumstances which surrounded anything
if there were lines that were made
fifteen years ago they don't count them
okay what i'm saying is that we've got
to wait for a super reporter okay talk
to me about what's going on as far as
russia is concerned we're told that
there'll be new sanctions um coming
forward quite soon tory party do take
quite a lot of money off the russians
don't they well any any any donations
which are received by any politician
from any party have to be from uh uk
uh donors we we no no one in in british
politics can take money from foreign
of course
and any such declarations have to be
properly declared on the wider russia
situation it's really important i think
that we're we're clear today it is
obviously very serious and we are uh
keeping a very watchful eye on what's
happening in the ukraine and any
decision by
uh the russian government to invade
would be a a disastrous act on their
part which would incur the harshest
possibility about the sanctions though
and
the russia report much delayed until
after the last election finally in july
of 2020 the uk welcomed russian money
and few questions if any were asked
about the provenance of the considerable
wealth well the uk is one of the most
robust uh money laundering regimes in
the world we we
and we're one of them
no one has done more to channel the
flood of money out of russia than
london's army of lawyers bankers and
accountants well uh look we obviously
continue to monitor the challenges which
flow from the fact that london is one of
the world's uh primary financial centers
and and obviously that is a challenge as
well as a huge asset to the united
kingdom that we are uh such a financial
hub when it comes to the wider impact of
of russian money we continue as i say
always to monitor the situation and we
are very clear that uh if russia takes
further action against ukraine then we
will further tighten the sanctions
regimes targeting those businesses and
people with the closest links to the
creditors johnson
has been very close to oligarchs in his
career 2014 he um 160 000 donation to
the conservative party by a former
russian minister's wife so that she
could play
tennis with him
and david cameron well
anyone who donates to any political
party has to be a uk national that is
that that is that is that is the reality
of of the the laws that we have in place
those laws are scrupulously respected by
the conservative party as indeed
i would hope they are by all political
parties let me put this last point to
you if i may and then i must let you go
again from the russia report a member of
the committee that looked into it stuart
hosey said there had been no assessment
of russian interference in the eu
referendum and that goes back to nobody
wanting to touch this issue with a
10-foot poll he said it was astonishing
that the uk government didn't seek to
protect the referendum by looking into
potential interference so you weren't
very interested before brexit why should
why should we believe you know there's
there's two things to say about that one
is that stuart hosey is an snp mp and we
know the snc's position
well we know the smp's position on
brexit which is obsessionally uh against
the other thing to say is that brexit
brexit britain are you rubbishing the
russian republic brexit britain is one
of the foremost opponents of the actions
of the putin regime and if you look at
the eu it is countries like germany who
are dragging their feet when it comes to
the the response to this crisis we are
the ones tightening a sanctioned regime
making sure that we support our nato
allies and standing up to putin in a way
which frankly is is leading the
continent rather than following it alok
sharma uh dominic raab rishi sunak
the prime minister um brandon lewis all
took money directly from the russians or
via their constituency by their
constituency offices in order to
continue impact sorry can you say that
no no one no one has taken money from
the russians that's that's that's let's
be very clear about this any any are
russian any no no people who are british
citizens it is it is vital we establish
distinction it is simply not true
in russia russian oligarchs one needs to
be a uk national a british citizen in
order to to make a donation any such
donations are properly scrutinized and
declared as part of any of those people
having links to russia do you think
okay any look there's nothing there's
nothing there's nothing wrong with any
with any person in business having a
link with what with any country as long
as it's legally acquired uh wealth and
how they choose to uh how they choose to
spend it at that point is a matter for
them even if it's 160 000 pounds to play
tennis boris johnson well look
look at the situation with barry gardner
and the chinese a few a few weeks ago
yeah
i didn't make it right no no but no but
to be very clear the idea that this is
some sort of unique conservative party
problem it is not there is always a
challenge about making sure that we have
a proper declaration regime in place it
is a problem then no well look to be to
be clear we they were always rightfully
scrutiny on this you accept that the
coffers of the conservative party will
suffer if you bring in new sanctions no
what i would say very clearly is that
there is a need to make sure that all
donations are properly declared that
which which they are there is always a
need to make sure that these things are
properly scrutinized which they can be
but it's also not true to say that this
is russian money these are british
citizens making donations to political
parties of their choice that is their
right i think it is important we don't
muddy the waters on this issue to do so
is to undermine a wider faith in
politics i believe british politics to
be fundamentally clean and i think it is
important we we establish that reality
absolutely it's good to talk to you
sadly we're out of time